- Pumpkin spice season is upon us.
So sorry if you hate basic (bleep).
I don't drink coffee.
So when I saw that Kourtney
Kardashian had released her
pumpkin spice latte recipe,
I was like, "You know what?
"Imma make it."
Pumpkin.
Magic happened.
Wait. (bleep)
I'm a messy (bleep), and I'm real.
Because if you're gonna try
something, why not try the best?
And I think Kourtney Kardashian
will not let me down.
I'm hoping that she will
make me a coffee convert.
And for anybody who
thinks that pumpkin spice
is like not real coffee
'cause it's pumpkin spice,
I don't care.
I'm counting it as coffee
for purposes of this video.
I'm going to Whole Foods
Market to get the ingredients.
Let's go.
Pumpkin pie spice, pumpkin
puree, organic maple syrup,
vanilla extract, almond milk.
Pumpkin puree has gotta be here.
There are two types of almond milk.
I'm not sure which one to
get, so I'm gonna get both.
Gotta be safe.
Found organic maple syrup.
Booyah, check.
Pumpkin pie spice.
All right, so I've got most everything.
I just need vanilla extract.
That has to be around here somewhere.
Vanilla extract, where are you?
Yeah, vanilla extract.
Which aisle is that in?
- [Worker] Okay, at the end of this aisle,
you're gonna make a right.
- It was right here the whole time.
I got my bag of stuff
and now I'm ready to go
to see if I can make
a pumpkin spice latte.
I went shopping.
Kourtney posted this with
photos of her holding pumpkins.
So I feel like this is
probably an integral part
of the pumpkin spice latte making.
So let's do this (bleep).
First I'm gonna measure
out the ingredients.
We've got a half a teaspoon
of pumpkin pie spice.
It's already smelling like fall.
Pumpkin puree.
Requires a can opener.
Do we have a can opener?
(beep)
All right.
Can opener.
I'm like way too old to not
know how to use a can opener.
Is this like a left-handed
can opener or something?
One tablespoon of pumpkin puree.
A little extra for good luck.
All right.
It's starting to smell a little gross.
One teaspoon of organic maple syrup.
I got both types of almond milk.
Because we're using maple
syrup, I'm guessing unsweetened,
so that's what we're gonna try first.
All right, one cup of almond milk.
Whoo!
And finally, two teaspoons
of vanilla extract.
One teaspoon, two
teaspoon, and some spill.
When a Tasty producer does
this, this stuff doesn't happen.
But I'm just being real.
I'm a messy (bleep) and I'm real.
Kourtney didn't include it in the steps,
but if you spill something,
you should clean it up.
Heat the almond milk in a
small pot over low heat.
So that's what this (bleep) is.
I'm just gonna pour it in.
I did get this fun spoon,
so I guess maybe you stir.
No, okay, it doesn't say stir.
Maybe it's mad that I don't
know how to froth almond milk.
The instructions say
froth for about 15 seconds
or until it's foamy.
I know what froth is but I
don't know what to froth is.
Is there a device I should be using?
Is there a frother that froths?
You know, while this is heating up,
I'm just gonna do a little, a quick Goog.
How to froth.
Oh good, somebody made a video.
- [Phone] It doesn't really work though.
- Thanks internet.
Okay, so Kourtney says this
should take eight minutes total,
so I don't, I feel like I'm
already waited too long.
And I think it's getting close.
All right, so we're gonna get
the two spots of espresso,
which Buzzfeed's providing.
Espresso.
Wait.
- What is the single espresso two?
Isn't it two single espressos?
What would that mean?
Oh, I hate, I hate straight
espresso, straight coffee.
It tastes like chocolate that
somebody burned and ruined.
Oh my god, wait.
Magic happened while we were gone.
It's like boil, oh no, it's, wait (bleep).
It looks like it's curdling?
So should I try this again?
(beep)
I'm gonna get rid of this
'cause it's curdled almond milk.
- Okay, well then, all right.
I did something wrong.
I'm gonna assume it wasn't me.
It was the fact that I used unsweetened
and we're gonna try again with sweetened.
One cup.
We don't want the milk to be hot.
We want it to be warm, so.
Is this even on?
- Oh, okay, good.
They definitely have a whisk.
I'm still doing what
Kourtney is telling me to do
with the heating in the
pot on the low heat,
but I'm also gonna add a vigorous whisk.
I'm already seeing bubbles,
so I feel already way better.
I think the bubbles are a little soapy
and they need to be a little more micro,
so maybe a little more vigor.
(discordant music)
Amazing.
Now we're on to step
two, and we're so proud.
We're gonna be combining
the two shots of espresso
with the pumpkin pie spice,
the puree, the vanilla extract,
and the maple syrup.
Step three, we add these
together in a blender.
(blending)
We're pouring it into a mug
and we're gonna top with the frothed milk.
We just garnish with a
little pumpkin pie spice.
It says serve immediately,
so I'm gonna do it.
(bleep)
I'm impressed, holy (bleep).
It's actually like good.
It takes the qualities I
don't like about coffee
and it shuts them up and it
replaces them with pumpkin.
I'm proud.
I think I made a great pumpkin spice latte
and I'm gonna see what other people think
of my masterpiece.
All right, let's go.
I'm out of breath.
Hey, Sabrina.
- Hey.
- Can I offer you some of
my pumpkin spice latte?
- You're so out of breath.
- I just walked up a lot of steps.
- Did you make it from scratch?
- I did.
- What's in it?
- This is a recipe from
Kourtney Kardashian.
- She has a pumpkin spice latte recipe?
- Yes, she does.
- I make her avocado pudding, actually.
- Is she like a pumpkin expert?
- Cheers.
- I don't know why I'm nervous.
- It tastes like fall.
I like it.
- The coffee tastes weak.
Is that--
- 'Cause it's almond milk?
- That's what I'm tasting, that blandness.
- Oh, okay.
- It's very watery.
- I don't like coffee and
I like it, so I feel like--
- You don't like coffee?
- This is why I was scared to tell people.
- No.
- You did a really good job, Sarah.
- Yeah?
- You should be proud of yourself.
- Thank you.
- It's Kourtney Kardashian's
pumpkin spice latte.
- It smells like egg nog.
It smells like a gingerbread
house, but melted.
- Why don't you just taste it?
What do you think?
- That's delicious.
- It tastes like lots of cinnamon.
- Okay.
- It's not bad.
If you steamed the milk,
it could become extra frothy
and I think that would really--
- That's, I should have
talked to you earlier.
It just says like to
heat it in the directions
and I sat there heating it
until it curdled and I was like,
this is wrong.
I have a lot of frothing issues.
- You have to froth?
I feel like my water
is just as frothed as--
- I guess that's something
I can improve on.
- All you've done is made
coffee with almond milk
instead of milk.
- Okay, you're making it
sound like I didn't do a lot
and try really hard, which I did, so.
- Thank you, Christian.
All right.
I'm gonna enjoy my spoils.
- [Christian] Enjoy.
- Yes, it's what I've
been working on all day.
- I have another one down there.
- [Man] Okay, good,
good, good, good, good.
- Hey guys, we're (speaking
foreign language).
Did you know it's Hispanic Heritage Month?
(speaking foreign language)
For more Latino content.
- Subscribe here!